hey guys my name is Jess McDonald and it
is top five time which means I've got
the five very best stories of the whole
gaming week for you so let's get into
them
this past week journey has themselves a
PlayStation press conference in Japan
and a bunch of awesome things came out
of that including the confirmation that
Resident Evil Revelations 2 is a thing
the sequel to 2012 s Resident Evil
Revelations game is coming to ps4 ps3
xbox one 360 and PC from the same team
who made the original even though the
first game came to 3ds originally you
won't be able to grab the sequel on a
Nintendo console publisher Capcom
observed that revelations 2 is going to
feature a new setting instead of having
Jill Valentine and Chris Redfield as
protagonist alongside a slew of other
awesome updates we got a Japanese
release date confirmation for
blood-borne from software sweet-looking
action RPG is hitting shelves in Japan
on February 5 while there's no official
word on US or UK release dates we can
probably assume it'll be around the same
time thousands pull the dinosaur game
from steam after the developers
disappeared from the internet that's a
weird sentence let's up some more story
the stomping land a multiplayer survival
game complete with prehistoric beasties
was funded on Kickstarter for over a
hundred grand and brought to steam in
May through its early access program
then this past week steam stopped
letting you buy the $25 game and no
explanation has been offered up as to
why a good guest though would be that
the dev no longer seems all that
interested in working on the game given
they've abandoned all of their social
networks finally in July a PR
representative posted that the
developers super crits contract had
expired and that they'd stopped making
the game anyway long dramatic story
short a bunch of unhappy backers lost
money and the game is kaput Simbel Ames
second-to-last today new updated 3df
models are coming into the world the new
3ds models are hitting Japan this year
and Europe next year officially with
what we can assume is a US release date
sometime next year since Nintendo have
said it definitely won't make it to the
States
in 2014 the device is unsurprisingly
region-locked
features built-in NFC and a stronger CPU
the existing models you'll also find
that there's an additional analog nub
and two new shoulder buttons also custom
covers which is sweet and exciting
because we're all individuals and
whatnot love stuff today I have a story
about a hermit who lives in the woods
and steals Game Boy games it was a weird
week then hermit was Christopher Knight
who decided to actually live my
occasional fantasy of running away into
solitude to play video games
the only issue here was that he also
decided to steal food clothing and
entertainment from neighboring houses to
survive night subsisted for 27 years on
his takings which included Halloween
candy and games including Pokemon
obviously because of all the robbing and
stuff he's now been arrested but with no
word on whether or not he managed to
catch them all we can only hope there's
another update in this saga ask you a
question of the day let me know if
you're a fan of early access or not and
if you've had any extremely good or bad
experiences with the service this week
on sites check out my thoughts on the
Kim series in the jist Skyrim lord
esketh scottish on and mary cash plays
the super creepy in the horror game I'll
buy her lullaby that's it for me this
week I hope you have an excellent
weekend and I will catch you again on
Monday
you